okay let's go back to the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 see what people want to
talk about we'll go to our caller from
the 6 to 6 area code who's calling today
from 6 to 6
hi David my name's Steve hey Steve
what's going on not much appreciate your
show so thanks for what you do my
question centers more around up so I'm a
very big progressive and I was a huge
Bernie supporter but at the end of the
end of the sari at the end of the day
like you I recognized the the moment
that we're in with Trump in office and
we can't just take a chance but it
occurs to me that given everything
that's happened with coronavirus and of
course oh boy a lot of accent in the car
down there I'm sorry I'm trying to cut
this call um what could it be in
retrospect or even now since we're doing
this little election would Biden is
Biden the right candidate overall for
the moment because he's seems more
normal so is he the right candidate is
he an acceptable candidate is he the
best candidate are all different
questions right so like you as a
progressive myself I'm to Burke to
Biden's left I would like to have
someone more progressive that's question
one is Biden the ideal candidate from a
political standpoint would all else
being equal without being ageist do I
think that we need to replace an old
white guy for lack of a better term with
an older white guy I don't know I mean
it's like okay you know I'm not I'm not
ageist or it's not really a question of
of that but it's it's more just like is
this the direction we should be going at
this point or do we need something that
we might call a kind of reinvigorated
young leadership maybe but is Biden an
acceptable choice given the
circumstances yes I mean he's acceptable
enough and that he's better than Trump
and that's who I'm going to vote for
right no no I understand that and I
fully agree a I guess more you know with
as you cover your covering polls from
Arkansas he seems to be down only by two
by the does and you see him very
competitive in states that a more like
Bernie Sanders versus I don't know
vision him being competitive in Arkansas
and
think fighting will win Arkansas but all
these polls uh suggest double-digit
leads for a trunk I don't know that if
Bernie were and of course we still have
to win we can't count our chickens
before they hatch rather but I guess I
don't imagine Bernie doing as well in
the polls if he were the nominee even
though he's my preferred guy it's I I
don't know the answer to that I mean
it's you know what you it's one of these
counterfactuals that is indefeasible in
the sense that what can we say you know
back in 2016 you had a big crowd of
people saying Bernie would have defeated
Trump if it had been Bernie instead of
Hillary now I mean you know you have
people saying Bernie would be doing
better against Trump but at the same
time Bernie did very poorly against
Biden but even early on Bernie was down
by two million votes I know it ended up
being much more but that was after
Bernie dropped out so I don't I don't
know that we gained much from the
analysis because we can't possibly know
the answer yeah no no fair enough no
that makes sense that was something I
was thinking about but by the way I
appreciate the work you know you your
voice sounds just like MSNBC Steve
Kornacki this is not Steve Kornacki
right no no no absolutely not
all right very good okay Steve thank you
so much for the call I appreciate thank
you have a good day
okay take care